two long-time political pros from both
parties are with us now they are
Republican strategists and CBS News
political analyst Leslie Sanchez and
Democratic strategist Joel Payne who is
the CBS News political contributor good
morning to you both Leslie I want to
start with you good morning because it's
the night that Democrats had worried
about and the night Republicans had
hoped for neither materialized so Leslie
what happened to this big Republican
wave we were all we were all kept
hearing was going to happen the
Republican wave turned into a republican
sprinkle uh and it certainly did not
have the winning the degree of wins Gail
that many people anticipated what's
fascinating about it is for all of the
polls and people's lead up that
Republicans were going to be able to
tilt some of those blue uh traditionally
Democratic seats Republicans had a hard
time kind of holding our own well we did
do well in Florida Oklahoma Ohio North
Carolina it's very very frustrating and
you're hearing a lot of conversations
already internally and a lot of the
blame game about what went wrong and two
things they're talking about one is the
Trump factor and two what does the
future of the party look like
um externally like on a national level
and everybody's talking about DeSantis
so there's a lot to unpack this morning
but I will say there's some the
positives are Republican Governors did
well Greg Abbott came one in Texas for
his third term and you're going to be
hearing a lot about Latino vote
Republicans did incredibly well on
Latino vote and a lot of those swing
areas and they solidified in Texas and
Florida as well
we can only imagine the jocking that's
that's going on behind the scenes in the
Republican Party Joel Democrats though
overall did a much better than expected
as well what what worked for them well
look outside of Florida I would say
Democrats I think figured out one that
abortion could be an issue that could
work for them particularly in a state
like Pennsylvania that looks like that's
what's going to carry John fetterman to
win that race it's almost like there's a
silent abortion vote that showed up in
the electorate that wasn't showing up in
the public opinion polling and I think
that that's going to be something that a
lot of Democrats are going to look to as
hey is this an issue we can continue to
be opportunistic about I also think
maybe Democrats held their own a little
bit more on talking about the economy
you know I talked to people who put
these campaign ads together run these
campaigns they said that the majority of
their messaging was about the economy
was about fighting inflation and by the
way it helped that President Biden and
Democrats had that inflation reduction
act back in September to count as a
victory
Leslie you mentioned former president
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis exit polls
showed that Republicans want Governor
DeSantis to run for president in 2024
not Donald Trump what does that mean for
2024. there's still a tremendous amount
of trump fatigue Nate and and even
internally and you're going to see that
division among Republicans and it falls
along gender lines traditionally you see
a lot more men who are Republican men
who are excited about a trump candidacy
the potential run again but when you dig
a little bit deeper and look at Women
Voters communities of color that have
traditionally have started to move into
the Republican Party there's not so much
a warm welcome they want to see
diversity of thought they want to see
different type of leadership and quite
honestly people are tired and exhausted
from all of the baggage and kind of the
cloud that surrounds uh any type of
trump campaign that said there's
tremendous excitement still on the
ground you cannot deny the support that
the former president has and his ability
to raise money motivate
individuals to to take sides so it's
it's to be determined
no doubt about it he wanted to be a king
maker during the midterms not sure if
that happened but Joel Payne Leslie
Sanchez thank you so much